[Music]
yeah
they're here what who it's the
undead not today
[Music]
Poltergeist
horror movies don't work with a
[Music]
[Applause]
Walther I
[Music]
know I just realized I feel awkward when
we didn't have the the spooky intro that
we usually have for the Halloween
Spooktacular we usually have an adapt
this just looks tasteless at that
point
oh do you have some scary sounds on your
soundboard there Yakuza yeah yeah yeah
yeah let me
see
yeah no not soothing sleep sounds true
I'm tired
now better that's just you all right
glad to be with you today on the
Halloween uh the annual Halloween
Spooktacular we used to do it live of
course on and then with Co we couldn't
do it anymore so we just decided we'll
do it in the studio and uh we have your
we do a a costume contest every year you
get a whole swag bag and a lock of uh
Gerald's hair no no yep yep you get a
lock of Gerald's hair so if you send in
your Halloween costumes with your mug in
the picture to me on Instagram or on
Twitter uh use the hash Spooktacular
you'll enter to win the costume contest
yeah and it's going to be announced
later by our uh our drag queen of
England before we it's a
costume well let's hit the quick rundown
then we'll show you uh who we are
wearing first off we're going to talk
about the history of Halloween here
briefly mhm and a lot of you been asking
who is Mike Johnson that's what everyone
said including the
house uh just broke this morning right
now it is 10:22 Eastern Hillary Clinton
was heckled about Epstein by a known
pedophile Hunter so that's that's a lot
of fun and uh did you know about this
fizer hid nearly 80% of coid vaccine
trial deaths and Gerald will explain
exactly how that happened some creative
math and on mug Club your winners and of
course uh the uh hockey incident this
was going around is it an accident or
murder my question of the day to you
before we move on is what exactly is
your favorite Halloween memory um you
know one that you can post on let's it's
not a crime
valid all right so uh before before we
get into anyone else's costume uh I need
to be admonished you do yeah yes I need
to be admonished so guys hit the
admonished button do you have the
admonish yeah got it
admon originally I was supposed to be uh
you know a failed Hamas paraglider now
to be clear failed right failed if you
remember we did a sketch about it
mocking the death of these Hamas members
so you know I feel like we have a pretty
good track record of we do yeah yeah of
supporting the Jews as opposed to
genociding them but then it turned out
that we were wrong that the clip that
was making it uh making the rounds that
was viral it actually was a Korean
paraglider this clip is not
Hamas yeah so then that's just a sad
clip yeah it is at that point so you
know we added a flag we added a flag to
the to the costume there to you don't
need to keep it up keep it up is the Mas
SC in you up good Lord we'll get to you
in a minute
they all right so let's go let's go
through the costumes Gerald who are you
wearing greed oh is good oh Stephen oh
well but I but I'm I'm also Black Rock
you're Black Rock Gordon Gecko and black
you're destroying the future of America
yes but for my game oh yeah and by way
by the way wonderful set tool man don't
be afraid to use the wide shot here
today because you guys put so much work
in uh Joe Lewis broke one of the giant
spiders he attack he he didn't mean
didn't mean
it but my my kids will not be coming by
the studio today we have uh we have a
high-tech Matt is uh well that one's
pretty obvious can face the camera there
we got oh Dylan mulany that's the best
one and I don't like it killing it
Yakuza who are you wearing I am Juan
Wick who Juan Wick oh Juan oh yeah oh
they killed your pero and then this is a
it kind of looks like happy death day
Thomas the Tank uh Thomas the East
Palestine Tank Engine oh that's a
different Palestine where the train went
America it affected half of our
employees it did and then uh in third
chair we pulled out all the stops when
you hear this you know him you love him
November 9th 10th 11th he's going to be
at good nights in Raleigh North Carolina
and his show off limits airs Tuesdays on
mug Club Brian Ken who are you wearing
sir glad you asked they they came to me
and they said Brian you've got the body
to play Ken I said thanks that's called
genetics and then I said let's throw a
hat on me the hat that Oppenheimer wore
in Oppenheimer so I'm barheim you're
barbin Heimer because they competed they
competed at the box office they competed
at the box office I said let's put them
together cuz we need more of that we got
to bring our we got to bring our country
together Stephen that's the reason I do
this show with the worst of Both Worlds
that's exactly right we have a mushroom
cloud and the Canadian tuxedo so
everything about that is yep took me a
while to get this my dye my hair this
blonde but uh it was worth it did they
whiten your this morning they they did
or is that just natural uh they did no
that's after I go to church somehow okay
all right uh so you send in your costume
costume you know what guys how long do I
I can't by the way this is I'm going
have to take one of these off take one
off it's fine this is part of the this
is the part of the Halloween spook Tac
here look guys I'm just going to I I
call I call this the tale of the show
that's probably going to have a lot of
problems
[Music]
that's that's spooky I already I already
can't see oh
no oh no there's way more B this there's
no sand in this it's just baby powder
fog terrifies me especially when I'm on
a boat it scares me because it was the
last film that the guy from Smallville
did no I was just saying you can't see
the Rocks cuz when I
navigate what I don't I don't know my
head phones
aren't you created fog and I was there's
going to be a lot today that you're
going to have to deal with because
nothing is where it should be we're kind
of almost like old people are artistic
like ah ah my drink oh wait the gun is
it loaded who fortunately there was one
so at some point today I guarantee with
the costume contest which is why we
announce it of course on mug Club you
might hear if you're watching on YouTube
or see
this which means head on over to uh head
on over to mug clip all right before we
get into anything else uh here's a Tik
tocker warning people you know Halloween
used to be fun it did now it's offensive
you could dress up as anything so we
lead into it you can dress up as
anything yeah unless you're Megan Kelly
and you suggest dressing up as Diana
Ross oh and then you get fired but you
get a $50 million gold parachute that's
not so bad it's not so bad no I mean I
would wear black face and perform a
menstrual show on The View to get a $50
million parachute I'm wearing black rock
in no you're not in any danger you're
the whitest man alive it's fine okay
that's fine yeah you're you're not
tricking
anybody so here's a and you may need to
put on your head I know we wanted to
reval but you may need to put on your
headphones cuz you're not going to hear
the clips I didn't want to mess with my
hair you take your hat off yeah you can
take the hat off now okay thanks you or
you can put the Hat on above the
headphones I could do there you go I'm G
to put my headphones okay this is going
to should probably go to clipped soon
huh there we go yeah so here's a Tik
tocker warning people you know we used
to warn people about for example like if
a film was rated R don't take your kids
or you know don't play with blasting
caps now they warn you that dressing up
as Native American is is hurtful it's
almost Halloween and I don't want to see
any of this or this and definitely not
this they tried to wipe indigenous
people off of the map they banned our
cultural practices our ceremony our
language our regalia so to see people
put on a cheap Party City imitation
costume of what we used to be killed for
wearing is deeply hurtful and
distressing not only that but a sexy
Pocas costume just perpetuates the
sexualization of our women which
directly contributes to the missing and
murdered indigenous women girls and two
spare people you are not respecting
honoring are paying aage to our culture
the way that you think you are when you
do this it is not cultural appreciation
it is appropriation when you do
this community that you claim to be
appreciating so please think twice as
you're shopping for Halloween costume
ideas because my culture is not a
costume I won't even think
once by the way that guy's not Native
American he has a unibrow and a five o00
Shadow he's half Lebanese and Irish
who's he fooling yeah Native Americans
are complet they're a hairless people
right don't sexualize our women fine
they're ugly happy yeah and by
the way not true at all as you all know
my crush as a child was a Native
American walk-on roll on Seinfeld with
the tobacco store IND oh Native American
women are are absolutely beautiful that
guy I would be willing to bet is not
that guy is he's probably closer to
being a member of Hamas than he is a
kamanche right he's yeah he's dressed
like a ball boy as well that's his
costume so I'd like to see his family
treat police he just reversed our line
it's not appreciation it's appropriate
that's exactly what you that's you you
twisted it it is appreciation and now
you're saying it's appropriate you know
who's not offended Native Americans no
they aren't and by the way you gave us a
lot of great costume ideas for next year
yes so thanks for that I think it's only
it's only offensive if you're dressed
like a Native American and you're using
real bald eagle feathers that's that's
where I drop what if I go around
scalping people yeah it's fine they're
dep on the people they've been taken off
the endangered list have they well
legals yeah in that case yep so scalp
them scalp them well they're bald stupid
white head that's not the same color as
the rest of your body stupid glor better
than all the other Hawks I know they're
not both Birds of Prey just an overgrown
Hawk yeah too dumb to realize when a
fish is too heavy you get caught in the
Bog you get what you deserve ball
legal what are they like is too big it's
like just let go of the fish no I can't
do it I got to eat yeah you're going to
drown fine flap your way out of the
water you know what it's a perfect
example too of how desensitized we are
because you watch nature Channel right
now all of a sudden I'm seeing things
that are 2,000 ft under the sea that
look like a glow Puck and I was like
well yeah sure I see that every day and
one time I actually saw in real life a
hawk pick a fish out of the lake and fly
I was talking about it for like two
weeks I know and it wasn't in 4k slow-mo
up close I was like do you see that the
F the bird had a fish it's
amazing I didn't even know they did that
so exciting you have to get someone else
to verify my dad who's older than me he
like what holy hell
a bird with a fish we must go there I'm
like it's probably gone now it's like
well I'll take my chances we sat out all
night you can't see it in the dark
Stephen yeah to see what you scroll
through immediately on Tik Tok all right
uh let's move on here a little bit of a
history of Halloween uh just because
it's kind of fun yeah uh let me ask you
this and and I understand where people
are are lining up here like as far as
Halloween you go to spenc one time in
platsburg New York there was Champlain
Mall comment below if you guys are from
upstate New York you remember play mall
I still have nightmares about that place
and uh but there was a hotel there was a
comfort end with a water slide down the
block oh this is all true these are my
childhood memories we used to travel to
platsburg New York to go to Champagne
Mall so we could eat Taco Bell cuz we
were raised in Canada which sucks and
then we would go to the Comfort in
because they had a water slide which by
the way didn't have running water down
the slide so you just left three layers
of skin just a dry SL a streak of blood
like could you just get wet first and
provide your own water but by the time
water slide is so it's I don't know were
there mirrors on the ceiling and the
comfort in as well it's kind of yeah
there was that was more by request okay
so dry water slide but I remember at the
platsburg New York the Champlain Mall
where there was a Spencer right next to
a Christmas store or the candle Yankee
Candle store and it was set up for and
you see Spencers and you see hell and
Satan and then you see the love and joy
of Christmas I was like okay one of them
is I I enjoy both but one of them is
clearly a better holiday that being said
true you do have some of the often new
Ultra charismatic Christians who who
take it a little too far I think there's
a way to and you can comment below I
think there's a way to celebrate
something that is a cultural holiday in
the United States uh and not partake in
some of the uh the Pagan historical
elements but there are also uh you know
elements of the Catholic church that tie
into this and the same goes for
Christmas we just kind of have to pick a
date so each year in Halloween it's
common to hear people equating dressing
up and trick-or-treating with demon
worship uh you draw your own conclusions
make sure don't celebrate this day but
it's not a Jesus day it's a devil day do
you understand that people literally put
like spells on Candy your children Tri
or-treating and dress up for Halloween
you think it's innocent you're opening
the door for those spirits and that
spiritual warfare and that witchcraft to
come into you and your children's
lives just make sure you don't
vote God how does democracy work I don't
now I just drank baby powder I'm going
to move my going blow the other way
here
gross so let me give you a brief so
here's a fast fact one okay uh Halloween
it's a hybrid of a of a Christian and
pagan holiday now uh to be clear there
was an ancient Roman Festival I think it
was pronounced Lura Lura UT and then in
609 ad the Catholic Church started All
Saints Day May 13th okay it was a
festival that was exercising malevolent
spirits and then they kind of they kind
of did this to co-op a holiday right
what happen is if you look at the early
church they were saying okay these pagan
people have a holiday they're already
celebrating how do we bring them into
the fold you know they probably already
have a day off work there you go kind of
like Labor Day let's just bring in one
of our holidays and you know we'll be
across the parking lot hey come on over
here ours is more fun it did the same 88
8:37 ad the Catholic church then moved
All Saints Day to November 1st to
coincide with the Celtic holiday uh SE
and so there was or sa however you
pronounce it Gowan sings a song strange
animal so it's Pagan Traditions that
were combined kind of co-opted by the
Christian church back then they mixed it
up they gave this holiday they created
all Hollows Eve and just to be clear
that's kind of what happened with with
Christmas now we're celebrating the
birth of Christ right and I understand
some people say oh it's de Santa is
demonic they'll say oh you know the tree
is Pagan yeah but again we don't know
the exact day that Jesus Christ was born
so they picked the day likely when the
Babylonians celebrated the winter
solstice they said okay we have these
people who we view as Pagan we want to
right we want to um prze we want to
bring people into the f so let's take
something they're already celebrating
and let's sort of you combine it h yeah
I like that it's kind of like modern
Fusion quisine only hopefully you're
saving Souls right exactly didn't work
holiday appropriation yeah that's all
appreciate your day yes and uh did you
have something you want to add to that
no no no no no fast I don't know it's
hard for me to hear uh fast back to you
know I don't know if you know uh guy
folks is actually the guy to blame for
trick-or-treating in America really
yes okay yeah the Irish they imported
guy fol oh that guy guy folks oh yeah
yeah the Vendetta what is it I just
don't want to say the word and then get
bleeped on YouTube oh guy Fox folks
folks I've used yeah I've used it in a
different that guy fxs now that guy FX
he does I mean you get a that mask you
cannot keep the ladies off you uh and
that brings us to the tale of the
folking
guy
[Music]
I mean it works can you take the Fate
off that or no you know what here we're
g that actually bring that brings me to
the tale of Thomas the Tank has bad
peripheral vision and is missing his
[Music]
timing you guys don't do it right
yeah
[Music]
stuck to my going to be one of those
days Tim all right take your M so they
imported the guy fox day uh with the old
world tradition of soing which was by
the way receiving treats in exchange for
prayers for lost loved ones that does
and by the way all you V for Vendetta
ass hats out there do you understand
that the guy first off it was a failed
plot it was a failed bomb plot and he
was looking to reestablish a religious
oligarchy oops anyways then in the 1950s
he had the suburbs right that they they
started kind of they were on the rise
they were so hot back then candy
companies sort of decided to capitalize
and it became modern-day
trick-or-treating the second biggest
holiday but do you know why the trick-or
treat part I mean maybe it's not
completely why but when they went when
they didn't have a lot of sugar during
the war the kids actually would go and
just like destroy people's houses yeah
they still do it in Detroit well they do
but that's just because they're angry
and their future doctors and lawyers so
they have to get that out of their
system but the the candy companies
actually started doing this and they
said this is at least basically it's
like the kids unionized and threatened
enough people to get candy and finally
got candy as an entire holiday I don't
think BR I don't think God likes
Halloween of cavities guys cavities
that's true that's true you know what I
mean did you forget about that I mean he
did he did give us teeth yeah I guess he
likes tooth decay okay I'm sure he
probably there could possibly be a way
to avoid it he had a hand in the western
price foundation I think they
predestination second second biggest
commercial holiday I didn't know that
yeah behind Christmas crazy it's huge I
thought Thanksgiving would be higher but
I mean maybe not no so if you're a
Christian out there if you're you know
is there a way to celebrate something
it's a cultural holiday it's not a
religious holiday in United States do
you think you can separate the two and I
think you know if you're dressing like
you know a demon covered in your own in
intestines like you're probably taking
it a little far different than like a
superhero covered in your own
intestine it's when you it's really
tough when you have like two or threey
olds you have to find a neighborhood
that's like stimulating but not too
scary yeah I mean I just the other day I
you know I was at the Costco I
myself there was a
display eight feet high and then they
put it on crates and I just walked by
you know it's all time I I mean you know
I had to use the bathroom and it's
they're like Turkish prisons yeah you
had Blazing Wings though so that's
really why yeah really I should really
blame Buffalo Wild yeah just
yourself that's a terrible costume who
are you guy who sh himself oh wow that's
s oh you really did oh oh God now I'm
guy who throws up everywhere there we
are guy
shits oh God what are you dressed up as
hepatitis yes it's shots okay it's
pronounced shots shot sry so let's get
into this now it's been long enough
where we with the frivolity but it's
Halloween right it's time for fun and uh
demonic uh sacrifice um what we know
about Mike Johnson okay so this is one
of those things when it was announced
and I tell you that I try and be as
transparent as possible I did not know
who this guy was and no one here who
does this for a living knew who he was
now once I saw some clips I said oh yeah
I remember him I I only remembered him
questioning uh uh Ray at one point
Christopher Ray and I go oh okay that
rings a bell uh but aside from that
there really isn't a whole lot that
people knew and I thought well this
probably is going to be a compromise on
all sides that they picked someone like
that turns out that that's not exactly
the case the more I learn about him the
more I like and so for our next spooky
lore we call this the
tale
of the unknown
[Music]
speaker it's just baby powder guys it's
supposed to be my with look at this it's
like a 2:1 ratio and you guys went with
10 to one oh my asthma okay piggy
sorry all right so October 25th Mike
Johnson Johnson is the name was as
Speaker of the House and of course Mike
Johnson is already making ways
mhm sorry nothing's going right today
wrong Johnson here's uh here's the right
clip yeah yeah I just want to make clear
first of all that I do not have the a
disease cuz I know a lot of you are cons
want to know that but a HIV virus sorry
wrong there just so many Johnson's uh
tool man do you have the Right One
queued up um can you see it yeah okay
here's the right this is Mike Johnson
new speaker here you go the founders
viewed the ability to amend the
Constitution as one of its most
important features we'll hear about a
proposed amendment introduced by
representative Ralph Norman to impose
term limits on members of Congress we'll
also hear about the balanced budget
amendment which would impose a measure
of fiscal discipline that Congress has
lacked in recent decades Mr Speaker do
you support additional Aid to Ukraine we
all do there there's um we're going to
have conditions on that so we're working
through what kind of what kind of
condition we want accountability and and
U and and we want objectives that are
clear from the White House Johnson is
funding the 143 billion in a to Israel
with cuts to the inflation reduction act
specifically you heard a cut that's a
walk cut
yeah man so sorry we got the wrong Clips
uh they yeah
what Y what why well that that that's
that's my my admonished button for the
day Mr paraglider yeah hope you enjoy
check his pants
yeah oh
God we are children yes we are poo poo
is always funny I'm always see I'm
actually seeing Stars uh let's let's
keep that to a minimum so who is Mike
Johnson all right uh here's what we know
let's go through these the fast facts so
you guys have these uh right at you're
ready here fast fact one boom Oh it's
spooky there we
go
um
spared no expense yeah no we spared
absolutely no
expense I really I would like to drink
something but I'm I'm I'm fearful of the
the that's like a 10 to1 ratio mostly
water but there is baby powder there's a
little bit yeah it's gritty uh Mike
Johnson okay what we know is actually
that uh he is a devout Christian so that
is something that we know he's been
pretty outspoken about it he's not a
super experienced guy so um we're going
to make all the references available at
lc.com or Link in the description so
let's go through I think we have four or
five fast facts that you guys need to
know on these key positions he is a
devout Christian which is why we um call
this the tale of no
[Music]
surprise they said it's curious people
are curious what does Mike Johnson think
about any issue Under the Sun I said
well go pick up a Bible off your shelf
and read it that's that's my worldview
now I really I do appreciate that answer
however however that won't answer every
question I mean yeah but I will say this
it answers has anybody noticed how good
his skin is I think he's 52 Jesus is
good for your skin sorry I mean it seems
to be that way a the Bible I don't know
if he's grinding it up like into a mulch
and putting it in well Retinol Serum
paste I'm just saying that Christianity
really clears up it answers most
questions but
it's
[Music]
it clears it clears the fog is what I'm
trying want to play the game wants to
play the game but here's the thing
here's the tale of uh the third chair
who doesn't understand that you have to
set it up by saying this is the tale of
Insert Title
[Music]
Here damn it all bod and no
brains I know I'm just hot yeah I hope
you're not buil not just bombs I hope
you're not like engineering our planes
for CR out so um he he's pro-life
Johnson in case you were wondering like
he does fall in line uh with a lot of
sort of what you would consider
mainstream Republican views but he also
would be considered you know Trump
populist in some ways which rubs some
people the wrong way not
me some people so Johnson tweeted this
after row was overturned uh he said and
now finally because roow v Wade was
overturned last summer and Louisiana is
now a proudly pro-life State we will get
the number of abortions to zero is what
he said
[Music]
so okay yeah there we go why making sure
you're awake okay I mean it's Mike I was
clearly awake I was reading a quote yes
but he's a boring guy we'll make him Fun
hit
like if yeah you're glad to have Mike
Johnson leading let's just stop with it
no no no no no hit like if you want
Stephen to be shocked more no don't hit
like if you want Stephen to be shocked
more that's where there is no thumbs
down button they did away with it so
just just hit like we could it for the
algorithm uh let me go into this next
one here's also prot traditional
marriage that's another key fact you
need to knowe uh he filed a supreme
court uh or I guess several uh briefs
against same-sex marriage as uh an
attorney for the alliance defense def
defense fund you really did electrocute
a little bit defense fund which is we
didn't have to Method act it like they
put a little shocker in my chair we just
could have done an
effect so uh the alliance defense fund
is an Evangelical Christian legal group
and by the way it's also a designated
hate Group by by the Southern Poverty
Law Center so it's hitting a lot it's
ringing a lot of bells right also the
largest Bell Megan McCain is upset about
all of the homophobia so that's a
ringing endorsement she said so we just
elected a raging homophobe to speaker
way to break stereotypes and win over
hearts and Minds you're just the basic
white broad version of Anna
Navaro love that raging homophobe I I'm
a republican but I like I like gays okay
fine I guess what is that even mean what
you pointed oh yeah by the way D
Feinstein here in studio Feinstein is
that what you were pointing to Feinstein
it's fine we put in all that work going
I'm still
dead wow that was a terrible voice we
put in all that work and you guys may
have missed it Diane find what do you
think I don't know why does she have
seaweed on her we pulled her out of the
ground was it wasn't a burial
sea fste like a pirate she may work you
guys just got a little crazy maybe they
buried her at Sea well that's Moss to be
fair that could be Moss she was she was
buried in a Pine Grove you going to take
off that one now you won't get
electrocuted anymore okay yeah is there
anything more annoying than someone
using cover of I used to be a Republican
or I'm a conservative but and you know
Megan McCain is just one of those people
anaro they you are sure to get a
contributorship or a spot on The View or
CNN or MSNBC if uh you're a turn coat
and by the way they don't care about you
they don't like you you're Judas they're
using you and remember one time she goes
I'm Republican chick who also likes sex
how do you think there came to be all of
these
Republicans it's like she just picks the
negative stereotype of conservatives
that the left tries to portray that the
left tries to perpetuate and says yeah
and I'm not those well neither is
anybody else you're just an idiot so
when idiots really don't like this
speaker it tends to to nudge me toward
you know his side his side of the
spectrum I go okay maybe this guy has
something to offer uh here's another key
fact fast fact number two let's make it
spooky
very nice yeah he also challenged the uh
20 that was not Sor just that wasn't
spooky at all laugh scares me a little
that was the most so that's a self
soothing boo yeah
laughs laughs are scary do no it's the
tale of what F it's the it's the tale of
creepy laughs and and when you combine
that with fog it's too long of a title
blow just go
blow
[Music]
I'm not good at this game dude I can't
I'm not when it it's a generational Gap
you never watched are you Frid of the D
yeah I never did God I didn't either
tell I auditioned for it and I was I was
a ringer I was brought in as a token
white guy I've told that story he did
yes it's in my mouth I don't know if I
told on mug Club I auditioned I was
playing a character whose last name was
Wang and it was the tale of The
Misfortune cookie and it didn't dawn on
me until I was reading the lines and I
realized I was the only n Asian in the
audition room I was like it's my first
audition ever really shattered me did
you get
it
a why is everyone so mean today is it
just because we decided tast costume I
guess those are your you and your cheap
tricks we have no treats so this guy
challenged Mike Johnson he challenged a
2020 election and uh he supported uh
president Trump during the impeachment
so uh let me go on through this we've
already done enough of that year we'll
go we'll go back to it uh he was one out
of 37 House Republicans who voted to
sustain objections against the 2020
election certification and he served as
part of Trump's impeachment defense team
here he is actually got a sense of humor
he posted this he has a sense of humor
which I like because you might think oh
Christian he must be a funy duddy uh
gloating outside of Pelosi's office
after uh Trump's impeachment uh
acquit yeah uploaded that that's awesome
I love that that's funny that's fun
that's good he's he's got a little bit
more going on than uh Mike Pence you
know he's he's he's got the kind of same
kind of biblical understanding but then
you know he's not you know they were
talking about I don't remember if it was
if it was Iowa or it was New Hampshire
they were going through some polls and
of course Donald Trump is Far and Away
number one Nikki Haley was number two
and then uh they they basically said and
since this was conducted before Mike
Pence dropped out but they made it a
point to say it was just a rounding
error so they gave it to the next the
next closest candidate on the list it
was less than
2% I just wish they would have said no
no change my Pence dropped out and no no
change for any it affected things zero
and here's something because we have
said this before people in the house
people in the Senate uh most important
issue of our time is certainly big Tech
censorship so key fact number three make
it spooky there you go is uh this guy is
by the way um he's he's very openly um
taken the fight to the left now I don't
know how much you can actually do let me
let me sort of give a caveat here is you
see a lot of these people who you think
are more conservative then they get to a
position of authority and all of a
sudden they start making compromises
yeah but it is important to have someone
who's at least starting off with all
right we need to address you know
section 230 we need to address uh the
utility sort of legal well section 230
let's just go through that where they're
basically treated as utilities as
opposed to platforms um and he's in
favor by the way of repealing 230 yeah
to be clear now a lot of people aren in
favor of repealing it but he's in a
position now where he might be able to
lead the charge to do something about
right I was about to say we'll actually
see what he thinks about 230 because now
he's speaker and he can hopefully push
this thing forward or if he's just
blustering like everybody else right and
you see a lot of that so here he is
actually questioning Christopher Ray um
on the Biden former Vice President Biden
administration's efforts uh to have not
efforts them having big Tech censor
Americans now before we go to it uh
couple things that I thought were key
and this is why we're showing this he
was asking he was drilling down on the
question who determines misinformation
and this is something we've talked about
in this show quite a bit because when
you have Jens saac and you have the
administration telling Spotify that they
should be getting rid of Joe Rogan or
censoring Joe Rogan that's a problem
when you have this Administration
working directly colluding with people
in meta and alphabet Google YouTube
right as it relates to vaccines and
lockdowns in which science is permitted
will get to the coid vaccine uh death
rate well not death rates the deaths
that were actually lied about that were
covered up by fizer when you see that
collusion you are no longer a private
entity and then he also goes on to uh
call out Christopher R when he try to
say no this this only has to do with
foreign threats again the reason that
matters is the Democrat Party has gotten
a foothold with pig Tech under the guise
of Russia Russia Russia that's what they
used and said we need to regulate this
more because we could have foreign Bad
actors affect the elections and as we
saw when you sat down and spoke with uh
with Mr Epstein with Dr Epstein um the
last election you don't need to get to
Dominion you don't need to get to the
ghost of Hugo Chavez rigging the votes
you can just look at the number of votes
that were switched through big Tech
intervention that changed the election
period I'm kind of amazed that
Republicans or conservatives win any
elections ever considering scary Google
YouTube Facebook Instagram Tik talk what
they do which is why we're incredibly
grateful for rumble and of course you
can join mug Club at lc.com mugclub we
don't you know we don't make any money
off of YouTube so uh I know other people
are leading that way now we've been
doing it for a long time here is Mike
Johnson the right Johnson questioning
Christopher Ray the evidence shows you
your agency the people that directly
report to you suppressed conservative
leaning free speech about topics like
the laptop the lab leak theory of Co
19's origin the effectiveness of mask
and coid 19 lockdowns and vaccines
speech about election Integrity in the
2020 presidential election security of
voting by mail even parody about the
president himself negative post about
the economy they did this under the
guise that it was disinformation can you
can you define what disinformation is
our focus is on malign foreign
disinformation that is foreign hostile
actors who engage in covert efforts to
our social media platforms which is
something that is not seriously in
dispute I have to stop you for time
that's not accurate you need to read
this court opinion because you're in
charge of enforcing it and your Bible ah
this guy makes the STIs look like Al
Franken I like his light of questioning
there he pressed him on this and said
get out International he's like oh no no
no no no we're looking at foreign
threats everything I just listed to you
was not a foreign threat right unless
you count Co well no it was it was from
China I get it but it was Ronda santis
talking with doctors it's doctors in
California it's us it's every tuber that
had the balls not everyone did to go out
there and actually say what was going on
those those were we're not Russian we're
not foreign misinformation Specialists
you quoted the CDC and resulted in a
suspension but that's a foreign election
interference claim now yes no it's okay
you're allowed to question elections now
you know that that was Neil Mohan Neil
yeah said yeah yeah you're allowed to
you know why and I remember that
happened we talked about it on this show
someone I said call me to the mat
because they're preparing if they lose
the next election they will say that
there was interference there was Russian
interference that's why they have to
allow it they allowed it right from 2016
all up until 2020 they said okay we're
not going to allow it now say it's
allowed again tell me that doesn't
affect a constitutional republic it
really is the biggest issue of our time
because if you can't actually speak
freely and I'm not talking about going
out and calling people to commit
violence you know like black lives
matter in the summer of love I'm talking
about questioning for example data
that's presented by people with a vested
interest in certain pharmaceutical
companies with opposing data from other
s scientists yeah that's what we're
talking about we're talking about
shining a light on corruption you know
investigative journalism is almost
impossible to do because you have these
big Tech entities that don't even honor
the laws of their state it's a single
party consent State I don't need I don't
need the person who is engaged in a
pedophile ring to consent to being
recorded on camera that's the whole
point to investigative journalism yeah
exactly and look if you aren't familiar
with what he mentioned a minute ago
about the Robert Epstein interview it
was just a few weeks ago go go out to
our channel on Rumble and find it and
watch it we'll put it out on social
media it will absolutely shock you
because everybody that's focused on
Dominion voting machines and all that
stuff look those things are important
but big Tech can swing elections from
here on out and you won't even know yep
yep you'll just wake up surprised and
think oh I guess my guy didn't win why
do you think France and UK Parliament
wants to get rid of Rumble yeah think
about that for a second they actually
want to get rid of a website that
actually that actually would be in line
with 230 that hosts any point of view
provided they are not breaking the law
right they actually want to get rid of
it yeah yeah France they the bird to the
enti government of France and the UK
parli s a letter saying that they wanted
Rumble to remove XYZ content they had a
whole laundry list and if not that they
wanted to ban Rumble from from their
lands which to me are largely irrelevant
how do you say rumble in French
rumel yeah yes
L just play it cool boys yes going to R
not like those dirty Ricans they don't
know a good Rumble when they see one I'm
going to go do a muscle up my strengths
will Amaze you I'm still very gay
yeah and Mike Johnson by the way he does
seem to be an actual conservative and
again this isn't the only reason you're
not just talking about you know rubbing
it in people's faces policy matters
values matter but it's a pretty good
sign when the left hates him as much as
they
do here is a sample the more we learn
about the man suddenly thrust into the
spotlight of how speakership the more he
resembles his version of the modern
Republican Party
it's a little unfortunate he was out
there saying the Dominion voting machine
that
cost he there pushing the crazy scandals
about how our voting machines were
broken the crazy conspiracies out there
he hasn't had to answer for that he
hasn't to answer the tough questions on
his gay positions he hasn't he did some
softball questions on guns last night he
hasn't had to answer about the fact that
he's for constitutional carry extreme
the most extreme gun views first speech
in his new
jobed that his election as Speaker was
an act of God talk about a bit of a
humble brag there his views on policy
are essentially what you'd expect from a
religious fundamentalist they're more
divisive man who appeals to all factions
of the Republican Party the Maga
faithful the social conservatives the
White nationalists and the horny
Beetlejuice
goblins 40 writers yeah the best they
can come up with fundamentalist making
fun of a woman who is actually pretty
she's an insufferable
Funt what's your show inside Jens saki
yeah
is that what it is inside with with that
doesn't even make sense inside what with
Jens saki pronunciation Spotify that gay
guy there he makes he makes gay William
look like Steve
Reeves can you believe the most exteme
the most extreme form of carrye the
Constitutional one the the fact that he
used that verbage I was like you realize
what you just said just call it
something else call it you know carry
without a without a permit which of
course I support but for your own dumb
listeners like oh my gosh you can carry
without a permit yeah like Vermont just
to be clear you can just go in purchase
a firearm at least it was up I don't
know if they changed it recently where
you can open carry conceal carry you
don't need a permit why because it's
your constitutional right and you go
through a criminal background check
anyway yes so they can't stand this guy
then again they hate every Republican
speaker let's just be clear about this
it's fun it's it's it the reasons they
dislike him are reasons that I would
like him but remember when these people
tried to make George W bush out to be
the most extreme right winger in
existence exactly now they love him yeah
well right now they go you know the I
just saw this on CNN the other day going
you know it's not like the days of
Ronald reer even George W bush the
moderate Republican I can't tell you how
many posters and punk rock albums I saw
comparing him to Hitler oh yeah Rage
Against the Machine no F you want to go
through the list yeah there was a rock
against Bush album mhm Green Day
American idiots it was I think it was
the biggest album of that year
everywhere on CNN yeah no wmds no wmds
every and now they said no no no we like
them now so the point is if they're
going to hate you anyway let your freak
flag fly Let your freak flag fly don't
try and find Common Ground based on a
lie it's ridiculous and we don't have to
do that I don't know if we've had to hit
the YouTube dump button so that's why
you can join mug club and the hell's the
difference I'm going to drink from
Gerald was smart because he put his
liquid in a can no I I have it in a cup
as well I just I blow it that way yeah
and my cup is that way I'm bad at
creating said I just you know I looked
at you and I was like I'll do it
different all right here's a fun story
this is just breaking uh this morning um
Hillary
Clinton sorry I threw up in my mouth a
little Hillary Clinton uh was heckled
and this was from a known pedophile
Hunter uh about Jeffrey Epstein so um I
I guess we I call this the I call this
the the tale of the canel pedophile
[Music]
enabler then you want somebody who's
going to get up every day hey Hillary
why' your H been visit afan Island 26
times is this really necessary is this
really necessary guys is this really
necessary is this really necessary
sir wow just drag him out 26 times by
the way yeah also why are you dressed
like a 2016 era Steven
Seagal can you play that clip again of
Hillary Clinton what did she she just
decided like she's just given up but
instead of giving up in a pants suit
she's like I'm going to wear I'm going
to wear the Chinese woou uniform hides
her girlle and you want somebody who's
get up every day hey Hillary why' your
husand
so the man in the video is Alex Rosen
who's known for exposing pedophiles this
is part of what it's become kind of a
hobby which is one of the few it's one
of the few Trends I like on social media
that's actually not so bad no it's not
so bad like that yeah 26 times is think
about that for a second yeah like if
your friend said you want to come to my
Island and you'd be like I guess once
yeah but on the 25th time what are you
going there for Al how great is that
Island just to hang out on the beach on
the fifth time with Kevin spacy and
Chris Tucker that is a weird Trio
something going if you go through the
call logs it's Kevin spacy Chris Tucker
Bill Clinton on that flight well they're
on their way somewhere else they're on
yeah they just stop cheap fuel yeah they
stop I think he plays it nonchalant the
pilot is like oh sorry as your captain
speak I forgot to fill up I don't know
where we're going to oh I guess we have
an island here we we'll check that out
wait that's not sex island is it I don't
know I never heard that's pedophile
Island I don't know but they have diesel
This Plane runs on diesel no no but uh
but we should take a sex break yeah we
should we got to take a just stop for a
day no anybody want a massage pedophile
Union
rules massage by somebody with small
hands P file I'm sorry did you say sex
break or sex day they can make it a day
both yeah let's make a day of it we're
on our way to I'm just confused we're
making a sex day trip yeah you think his
wife was like 26 times huh you guys must
be close yeah ah it's a boy thing I
remember they tried to tie it in like
like for example like with uh they
mentioned like Alan d you can see he was
like on there like once or twice like I
don't want to be here uh they try and T
like oh what about Republicans like if
you understand the history of Epstein
and Donald Trump we've done a whole
segment on it he kicked him out of Mara
Lago as soon as he found out that he was
a creep yeah Bill Clinton and Alex B
sorry Jeffrey epsteen did I say Alex
Epstein earlier Bill Clinton Bill
Clinton Alex EP different okay Jeffrey
Epstein and Bill Clinton were like this
yeah they had a time share on that
island that's a time share when you go
there somebody 26 times that's basically
your time share with Jeffrey which by
the way you may find me on the on the on
on the log but the reason is because if
I attended their sex Island time share
seminar I got a free flat screen did you
get the freeth this is back when plasmas
were very expensive they were like
$2,000 yeah but they didn't give me one
it's true come on I only got the soundar
nice so here is uh Alex uh Alex Rosen by
the way and his team just in case you're
not familiar with him uh pretending to
be 14year olds or I guess he's
pretending to be a 14-year-old boy I
it's a group of them I don't know if all
of them are pretending to be 14 that
might be tough to pull off but one of
them is pretending to be 14 and they
catch a huge creep I was here to mentor
and to just rub Lube cuz I heard his
skin was like you know a little bit bump
can you shut up can you shut your mouth
then you said I'm in right now and I'm
horny as my is hard as a diamond in an
eye storm right now I mean how hard is a
in in a come on my is as hard as a
diamond in an eye storm right now I mean
how hard is that that's got to be pretty
Rock Solid and then you sent a picture
your I think you might have been
bluffing did you really tell a kid that
you're
hard and then the guy goes to jail wow
is that a real cop uh no well I don't
I'm not exactly sure with that clip can
hey Mission Control can you give us the
context there because otherwise I would
be police impersonated police officer my
favorite one find this and give it to me
I don't know if it is Alex Rosen is
where he lets a guy know at a
supermarket he walks up to him and he
goes hey we know who you are you know we
were the ones pretending to be a 17
whatever 14-year-old boy and uh he goes
in about 5 seconds I'm going to yell to
everyone here in this grocery store that
you're a you're a pedophile you're a
child molester okay you ready and the
guy just sort of
goes he just accepts his fi got a
pedophile here got a child molester the
guy tries to walk out of the uh the
grocery store the guy just accepts it
but can I go can I ask can we go back to
that video for a second um the cop is
not real and but but can what is going
on with Alex rosen's shirt that's a very
tight I think he's he's trying to he's
trying to play an underage which is hard
to do he's that's not an under I'm kind
surprised that that guy went for it yeah
that's a kid who's been eating there are
a lot of hormones in the meat I say they
can give us some more context to that
one cuz that does not look like him
being a 14-year-old boy who's going to
buy 14-year-old boy huh what that's
aying yeah he was pretending online to
be a
14-year-old showed up in basically in
costume again this is breaking right now
now by the way some G uh some gas liting
accounts on Twitter they've been trying
to just completely just just paper over
this saying things like a an
anti-semitic Trump supporter dragged out
of a Hillary Clinton rally after he
falsely accused Bill Clinton visiting
Epstein Island first off falsely no
second Alex Rosen is Jewish so the
idea he's anti-semitic everything about
that is wrong he's one of those Jewish
Nazis yeah Bill Clinton had a fast pass
on Epstein Island exactly I 2 yeah yeah
no lines the custom like come on and I
got him yeah fly out Bill thanks for
coming back Mickey Mouse here stamped on
his hands I'm in the club yeah he's got
a ball gag and Lube about Kevin spy and
Chris Tucker yeah well they have a lot
in common that makes absolute it doesn't
make a lot of sense yeah man no I'm
sorry they have one thing in common
apparently yeah well they like little
kids do not didd kids it's no good
diddling
kids so in conclusion show support for
Alex Rosen and hopefully he doesn't kill
himself with two shots to the back of
his own head but you can comment below
and show him some love because he's
probably going to see this segment yeah
for sure all right that's probably the
best segue by the way actually when
we're talking about this to uh you know
Walther is a sponsor to the show and you
guys you know we've talked about this
before there are a lot of great Firearms
out there it's we're protected by
Walther here at the studios I just have
to show you this so you don't look I'm
not I'm going aiming it in a safe place
I'm aiming it at dead Diane Feinstein
Feinstein Steen Stein there you go there
you go okay everyone see that's loaded
we're not doing a rust thing no magazine
in there but Walther look there are
great Firearms out there we've talked
about this you know certain points like
Mercedes it's like BMW but just try the
Walther go to Wal arms.com find a dealer
near you we've taken people to the range
you know we did it with these two girls
from a change my mind for example who
had never actually been to a range we've
done them with experienced Shooters and
it's almost like using cheat codes the
triggers if you just Google Walther PDP
their latest firearm Walter PDP review
Bing it for ask the little bent back
paperclip on your word app for all I
care ask
Jeeves they're the best kept secret in
the firearm uh industry cuz they don't
have these giant military contracts so
they don't necessarily go out there and
just sell you products that aren't
effective but if you read reviews from
independent third parties everyone's
like why why aren't more people talking
about this so huge fan all right yeah
you been you've both been awfully quiet
you feel like leaving me to die in the
here today I call this the tale of might
as well be empty
[Music]
chairs boy it gets worse when I try and
blow it off my desk like it's angry at
me still spooky though still spooky
still scary right guys fog I can't see
him it's not fog Oh I thought we were
still talking about I thought F was Guy
fogs oh dry ice I feel like this story
fits for Halloween you know deaths Co
yeah this story is spooky because people
died right real and we destroyed entire
economies so this uh that some would say
that's spooky yeah the next I mean
spoiler the next entity is sent more
sent more souls to the shadow realm than
sh
soon I love it it's a great reference
and Johnson and Johnson a come on just
because of the contract just because of
the contracts yeah yeah yeah they Tred
yeah that's the marshals of
vaccines so there are actually some
deaths that were again the standard
isn't just okay what science was
available it's what science was
available at that exact moment in time
that you discounted because it didn't
serve your narrative that's when people
say oh we we did the best we could no
you didn't no you didn't you suppressed
as much as you could and that's what we
call this next story The Tale of the
cursed vaccines uh oh man
[Music]
long that was a tale of the longest
title that made no sense don't you don't
[Music]
you
also just a reminder as I came to
lockdown this is the tale of Sweden got
it
[Music]
right there's like no sand in this no
it's just baby powder straight up baby
powder it's just it could be Gold Bond I
have no idea don't think that I don't
see it in your hand I know I not diet
tenacious Earth vaccines are important
but so is exercise and sunshine
the tale of living healthy
[Music]
no I smell like a baby after he shed his
a rest moment yeah we'll we'll work this
out by next
Halloween no we won't so there was a new
study and by new I
mean I mean two weeks old so DB two
weeks old and you probably don't know
about it we went through CNN we could
find zero in its archives know what
you're thinking rounding error no so the
study showed that fiser hid nearly
80% of the deaths from its coid vaccine
trials in order to get uh the emergency
use
authorization
80% wow of deaths zero media coverage
specifically this study found again that
was accessible and suppressed at that
time the cardiac related deaths were
3.7 Times Higher in the vaccinated uh
population than Placebo jeez and fizer
delayed the reporting of deaths of the
vax trial which quote again all
references available lth credit.com
before you want to ban us here at
YouTube I think we're allowed to talk
about this now I hope so quote allowed
the fiser emergency use authorization to
proceed
unchallenged and so the question becomes
and Gerald you can help explain this a
little bit um how was fizer able to
delay the reporting of the de right this
is the creative math when people say
trust the science right I believe that
that statistics are important but people
said there are lies damn lies and
statistics I believe that was Mark Twain
that is when you are dealing with giant
government entities at least partially
true if you can manipulate statistics
through these sorts of uh I guess tricks
is really actually it's appropriate
today of timing and moving numbers and I
wonder I wonder if they had any
Financial incentive just so you know
fizer just reported a third quarter loss
of $2.3 billion loss net loss not profit
going down loss I call that the T
of the rhetorical
[Music]
question I don't know if I'm shivering
cuz it's so scary or just cuz it's super
cold and I have no clothes on probably a
little bit of but look so what fer did
is they used the reported date of death
instead of the actual date of death for
people so you and that stretched it by
up to about 18 days right there's a lag
yeah exactly right and they knew that
but here's the thing s vaccinated
patients and by the way you have this I
think I think you guys can access this I
don't know if it's Pub metet or if you
have to have a uh I don't know people
need to have a login because we have
access to those uh but the VAC
vaccinated patients it's 18 days and the
placebo patients 5 days as far as how
they were measuring they were reporting
the death the delay so why would you do
that why would you change how you report
so that's the big thing some people will
come out and say look the number of
deaths wasn't statistically significant
well they hit 80% of them so that's
significant and they also treated their
own data differently when it came to
something that made them potentially
have to explain or look bad and
something that didn't so that's why
people are asking these questions and
why the media should be digging further
into this because the reported date of
death is what they should have been
going to right so they they used that
later death and that allowed them to
report most of the deaths after the
emergency actually have a I have an
answer for that because sometimes when
people die it takes a while to to
establish cause of death so a lot of
times if you so if you're in a trial and
the trial I think was about 30 people
pretty small if you're in a trial it was
44,000 why would you say this air I saw
you and Gerald arguing about it before
being on air and he correct it's it's
many the 44,000 was a was a trial I
think that said that was looking at
whether or not it was effective against
severe infection as far as deaths are
concerned that was from the smaller
group no right no no the death was
coming from a much larger group coming
from the larger group Tri so look look
it's very but but your point here's the
thing your point is valid if they didn't
immediately list people who shot
themselves in the head with a shotgun as
a CO death right exactly that's my
counter argument so here's the thing
motorcycle accident Co death vaccinated
myocarditis when in your
mid-30s it's going to take a while from
to get the coroners report when is it
coming in I don't know we didn't hire a
coroner right but isn't there something
where legally if you die they go this
had nothing there's a there was a review
that says he didn't die from the vaccine
he died from some other cause right
needs to be applied equally to the
placebo group that that's that's the
whole point of this it isn't just about
the numbers even though the numbers are
pretty staggering that should make you
dig here basically right so you can find
out a little bit more about it but why
did they treat the people who are
vaccinated differently than the placebo
group and why if what you said is true
Brian why would that matter what group
you're in if it takes time to discern a
cause of death then why would it take
longer in a placebo group than it would
takeen a group of people that were
vaccinated took longer the vaccinated
group took longer than the vaccinated
group I'm saying 5 days in the placebo
group 18 days for the vaccinated either
way it should not change but this is the
tale because this is the tale of of
questions that have no answer cuz it's
not convenient no no no they have
answers
hello yeah you don't know the if you
found you're not giving us an Out tool
man let me do it again they have
answers do it tool man did you lose the
blow or I will I can't tell
[Music]
am all right this is the tale of I'm
Breaking All the Rules no I refute
[Music]
I hate it I hate the Spooktacular
there's about to be another death it'll
be all right so let me just read this
really quickly then toss back to Joel by
delaying uh the recording of these
patients deaths and by not using the
actual date of death this is from the
study this is from the news here that or
I guess the news study I should say two
weeks old it's not really news but no
one else has really covered it uh their
deaths were not discoverable at the
critical juncture of the uh emergency
use authorization approval process so
this is one of those yes this is one of
those situations where I had read this a
couple weeks ago yeah but what happened
is because we go through news all the
time right and so I saw the headline and
I read it and I go okay 3.7 times the
death rate yeah the inre death and I was
thinking yeah that's a study that shows
the myocarditis and young individuals I
didn't realize that this was a new study
specifically relating to the fact or new
data that showed that fizer hid hid the
death rate that they used or they used a
different standard of death rate for the
VAC patients versus to get their
emergency use authorization so this is
really big this is about something that
we now know definitively took place
before you were fed that lie yeah even
though it wouldn't be acceptable right
afterward uh for people say hold on a
second uh if you look at vs and you look
at there seem to be a lot of adverse
effects and them saying no no it's fine
we did the best that we could that was
still a problem but now it turns out
this is Monumental beforehand they knew
at what point is it negligence leading
to the death of innocent people yeah and
by the way when this was put out did you
hear anything about there being
potential for 3.7 times the number of
cardiac related deaths for people who no
you didn't hear any warnings at all from
the government you had nobody telling
you that I heard it would stop the
spread yeah it would stop the spread
nobody else would you cat there was
absolutely no doubt about that no
correct remember Rachel mat it's very
simple if you take the vaccine and
someone has Co you can't get coid then
L's like you can get
Co
[Music]
right way like they weren't close to a
Shore Brian what they saw was billions
of dollars that is what they saw and
they saw Li if you ra questions if you
raise questions you were censored ladies
and gentlemen including scientists who
are in the field of Immunology right and
vaccinology which are two words I I like
to Let's assume that they started off
right with altruistic motives let's
assume that I'm not but let's assume
that this happened early enough that
they should have turned around just oh
okay it no warned us nowhere else on
God's green earth or no other point in
history certainly with modern medicine I
should say if we're talking about
leeches you know to suck out the blood
letting all that I'm talking about
modern medicine would something like
this be foed upon well they shut down
the economy though so so when you've got
when youve when you're doing this
operation warp speed and you've shut
down the world's economy there's a
little bit of pressure on everybody to
get this thing out couple deaths that's
fine but we got to get things buzzing
don't shut down the economy yeah just
open it up anyway that would have been
better if shut down the economy yeah
yeah and so then when they found out oh
this isn't going we thought it was they
decided to hide their data that to me is
a crime against humanity if you want to
say that George W bush who they like now
was guilty of war crimes and of course
Barack Obama would be as well and so
would Joe Biden if you want to say that
they are guilty of war crimes you would
certainly have to say that fizer with
this new emerging evidence is guilty of
uh crimes against humanity now of course
to go inside with this data uh we have
footage of them yeah attempting to hide
their data as it was leaked the hell is
that
[Music]
yeah all right so uh
okay oh again stff sorry jald what else
do you need to add to this so look the
one of the interesting things about this
is that uh they couldn't find any reason
for them to have done this they couldn't
come up with any reason for people to go
okay we're going to have an 18-day lag
here and a 5-day lag here and by the way
after that period of time after they got
their emergency use authorization they
changed it back the lag went away this
is from the stud let me read let me read
the quote the length of the reporting
delay decreases significantly after the
emergency use authorization application
is submitted there is no reasonable
explanation for this difference given
that a similar trend is not observed in
the placebo subject so we've said this
you're not a free citizen if you live in
a country with laws it's whether you
live in a country with laws that are
applied equally the same applies to
science and and I hope that this opens
some eyes here well people say what are
you a clim Den well hold on a second do
we run into with a lot of these a lot of
these studies as it relates to climate
science which they've said by the way
will be eventually the next Co that this
this the left has said hopefully Co has
taught people that we all can act
together you know in in a in a in a
Monumental way for climate hold on a
second let me just give you some very
clear examples that everyone will agree
on was it suppressed at one point in
time that batteries were non recyclable
batteries and the mining associated with
them was actually really bad for the
environment was it at one point in time
complet discounted that you were a quack
if you said hold on a second solar
panels actually could figuratively and
in many cases are worse for the
environment because they require massive
amounts of energy to produce and then
they are not effective in producing
energy themselves so if if that is
something that we can now agree on
because even the left is changing their
policy to try and create eco-friendly
solar panels that's the funniest
I've ever heard in my
[Music]
life hey then maybe do you look at the
giant money that's gone into Pockets
like cylindra at that point do at some
point do you maybe say well if they
can't make the electrical cars work in
California maybe that's a tip off that
this isn't necessarily about what's best
for the environment hey did an English
did a British High Court rule that there
were nine significant errors in the
academy award-winning documentary and
Inconvenient Truth which by the way also
related to uh Al Gore sitting on the
board at Apple what the hell does he do
when he's collecting billions of dollars
I'm just saying if we see this now
irrefutably with what happened in Co we
saw it happen ironically at warp speed
yeah I do think I do think there are
some things that people want to tell you
are settled science that are absolutely
not settled science it the more someone
says it's settled science it usually
means it's not now I'm not just being
simplistic and saying that applies to
everything but for example when people
talk about density yeah right when
people talk compare helium to oxygen
they they don't have to say it's settled
science it's settled science helium in a
balloon because of it will okay it's set
no they don't they just go look watch
it's observable okay all right got it
yeah you know someone says that hey
human beings need a certain mixture for
example of you need a certain level of
oxygen to breae you can't get it if
you're in water or you'll drown they
don't say hey if you go underwater for
you're going to drown it's settled
science it's sett it's always applied to
things that can't be observed
necessarily in real time now I
understand that the laboratory
conditions are required that more
complex science can't necessarily be
observed by the human eye I get that I
understand that it's not lost on me but
when they tell you something is settled
the vaccine is settled science why are
you a science denier M then they tell
you so that's the first thing if they
are shouting at settled science that's a
lesson I would say immediately your
antenna should go up your meter
should and if it's combined with large
sweeping pretty nebulous policy
proposals so in other words if we have
it settled science therefore shut down
the economy and everyone needs to get
this vaccine from one of three companies
by the way they very wildly some need to
be refrigerated some don't and we
how ituns we you answer and we can't
tell you it settled
science larg fundamental change to the
American way of life that I can I can
remember In Our Lifetime yeah does that
apply to for example it is settled
science therefore the Paris agreement
before that it was the coyo protocol
before that it was the Montreal accord
or was it the Montreal agreement the
Paris Accord I know it's coyo protocol
point is it's the same and by the
way in there it's settled science
therefore China's one child policy it's
settled science therefore there are more
than two genders how many we can't
answer that yeah it's infinite but if
it's settled science don't you have an
answer so when someone screams and
silences you saying this is settled
science and it's appe an appeal to
Authority
FY in
combination with huge multi-trillion
dollar policy proposals usually created
in back rooms through International
forms of government and committees who
don't have any oversight or
accountability that's usually a good
sign not always don't accuse me being
reductive it's usually a good
sign that it's not it's usually a good
sign that maybe it's junk signs that you
know what you are at least well within
your rights to question it and that's
why I call this story The Tale of
clearly not settled
[Music]
science
so look let me just add to that it's
it's not just settled science because of
that but when you see the mainstream
media completely avoiding the topic on
settled science and not allowing people
to have differing opinions and not at
least just searching it out wouldn't it
be great right now for the mainstream
media to pick this story up and to tell
every single American why it's bogus and
have the facts and lay it out wouldn't
that be the best thing to do if it
really truly is false and is going to
lead people astray where are the people
who oppose carrying firearms where they
say if it's saves one life right exactly
all right yeah yeah the how about the
80% of the lives that were lost that
were hidden whenever there's a
treaty or an accord a cottage industry
grows up around that if you pass a law a
cottage industry grows up around it so
there's a lot of money invested interest
in keeping that settled science settled
science right and we want you to run
this yourself so by the way we could
find no reference of it for example at
CNN or most of the I hate to use
mainstream media because no one watches
them but the Legacy Media forly known as
mainstream search it right now on Google
we can bring this up we just did this
this morning it says it looks like the
results below are changing quickly if
you search fer and vaccine
deaths I don't think it's search fer and
vaccine deaths bring that back up it
looks like the results below are
changing quickly how about you show me I
don't know anything Google hold on let
me let me just just leave that up for a
second is what it it looks like the
results below make us look really bad
yes so don't click I don't I don't
understand this you typed in the oops I
shat myself self
search we did many Google searches yeah
so for example we had fiser hid Co
testing deaths we ran a search fiser Co
vaccine testing deaths we ran a search
80% of coid vaccine testing deaths
hidden by fiser zero articles about this
study from any quote unquote mainstream
media sources and it was published two
weeks ago again search yourself comment
below let us know what it is that you
find I really this is crowdsourcing if
you can do it on YouTube if we're still
there do it there just because there's
nothing I like more than to be a pain in
mohan's ass that's true and we like that
too but look I I just I will defend the
mainstream media because they actually
do have a lot of very creative reasons
for the sudden rise and cardiac deaths
among typically pretty healthy people
around the world so I think that's the
that's the the tale of the Unexplained
but settled science bizarre heart
issues
[Music]
such a long title I thought we were
rolling into a clip so I had some
Grace just a collage bring up the
collage for br collage hurry give him
some cover all right can we read these
we have ABC News Rising heart disease
May explained may be explained by
extreme weather weather conditions what
keto diet links to higher risk of heart
disease new research shows oh my
favorite in Black solar storms may cause
up to 5,500 heart related deaths in a
given year yeah yeah but it says here
snow shoveling which is a euphemism for
cocaine yes oh W okay so there is that
video games could trigger deadly heart
problems in children finds new study
yeah you hold second let me bring this
back up this car fumes from exhaust and
heavy heavy breaking raise risk of heart
attack study suggests that's not new
like if you if you wrap your lips around
the exhaust of a car you probably are
aiming to go you're probably trying to
punch ticket and one thing University
student dies of Joy did you see that I
saw that bottom right that's what eating
same fruit every day could increase
heart it's like hey hold on a second
hold on you go to your doctor like you
go to your
doctor I have I have stroke face I have
bells face like huh uh have you changed
anything recently uh I got injected with
multiple experimental mRNA yeah
injections I don't want to use the term
vaccine because it's kind of anything
else youve been doing hm you haven't
been eating apples every day I ate one
every day it would keep you away not
apples I eat jelly that's a fruit I ate
an apple every day specifically not to
see you a preserve a jar of jelly will
keep the doctor away other reasons let
me let me just let me name one they said
taking cold showers that are too cold
but then wait a minute taking hot
showers that are too hot no you got a
Goldilocks you got a find those
Goldilocks baby bear that you got
it's just right and by the way also cold
porridge will give you hard
diet thank God I don't want to be on it
anymore I'm too shredded gardening he
died of being shredded gardening
gardening daylight savings time my
favorite Daylight Saving leads to cardia
that one we can go with daylight her
vote for a candidate who just proposed
getting rid of daylight savings time and
didn't even know where Ukraine was
that's actually true daylight savings
apparently when you miss an hour of
sleep it's bad for your heart so let me
just recap this for you before we go to
mugclub in our costume contest okay and
and Brian's going to be at good nights
you can go to brian.com and a show a is
here on uh here on Tuesdays November 9th
10th 11 uh okay so here's what you need
to know the mainstream first off the
mainstream media and a lot of these
Outlets uh they obviously recognize for
example what is settled is there is a
rise yes in heart complications in
cardiac complications no one is denying
that at this point okay so that's kind
of the Common Ground that we start with
otherwise you wouldn't have New
Scientist Daily Mail me or the Sun
Express Insider New York Times times
insert Washington Post insert all the
Publications here addressing the issue
of a staggering number of uh Rising
heart complications and the reason that
that is really using the scientific
method is because we have a comparison
which is all time before uh coid and the
vaccine all right the MRNA injection so
everyone acknowledges that and then one
side says well hold on a second could it
have to do could it perhaps could we
scientifically make the argument that it
may to do with a novel experimental
injection that has not been tested or at
least put through the same rigors as
other approved injections that we
basically foisted upon the entire not
just American populace but the the
population of the World At Large and the
other side says no no no no you must be
mistaken the reason we believe and we
all agree Common Ground we can have a
civil discussion here on the increase in
heart attacks myocarditis and other
heart related complications is you may
have people who are taking a shower that
might be slightly too hot slightly too
cold they could be waking up drinking
cold water while going out gardening in
their backyard picking fresh herbs which
may lead to them eating the same fruit
my God every single day and God forbid
that they be joyous or they engage in
shoveling snow or through no choice of
their own they happen to go through
daylight savings time we believe that
these things obviously uh lead to
increase in myocarditis settled science
yes but but how about the fact that you
kept people indoors and they didn't do
and you closed down gyms does that have
anything to do your lockdowns have
anything to do with the fact that people
were sedentary stressed out no it's an
apple a day that's pretty clear and then
you have the media and big Tech say yeah
yeah yeah we'll go with that so again
I'd love to see you run your searches at
what point do you how often do you have
to say Alex Jones was
right seriously aren't you getting tired
of it at this point I think everyone has
been turned into a conspiracy theorist
and we have to by the way hit the like
button share you can join mugclub
because if you are watching right now on
Rumble you can click the button you get
to continue watching where we have the
winner of our costume contest I can't
when it when you look down it just looks
like you're looking into a rock it's
just it's a very silly did this he
resting on it ignas is
good and
[Music]
so oh no I can control the tail well
listen I can control the tail of the
thing I can't control being electrocuted
maybe you'll be a little less Lippy
because we are going to be
announcing the winner to the costume
contest and here to do it you you know
some people say hey who who I have a
special treat for you in fact oh for me
yeah for this guy we have this guy
coming in at the season it's the season
of the drag queen of England the drag
queen of England fourth chair oh
absolutely so I believe I thought we had
the sound effects do you not have the
music there you we got a stinger foring
attention oh you a stinger for it would
be the time that's on Tim okay hold on a
second go to the Stinger
[Music]
guys oh that was a l than I thought wow
yeah you guys you a build in much grace
Time there a she's back make sure you
cross those legs all right who are you
wearing you have to move the microphone
over yeah this is the whole thing sexy
meter just hit red hot here it's the no
you're not the Queen of England oh what
am I you're you're the drag queen of
England oh the drag queen of England no
wonder why I look like Hillary
Clinton by the way for everyone who says
that gay William is just a character I
make up to get away with you must not be
a member of mug Club consider signing up
right now on YouTube you know what this
is an act of Mercy to you today now that
he she is in here uh you two piss
[Music]
off